ethereum
is the second best cryptocurrency in the
world and due to its popularity
everybody looks up to its performance in
the crypto market
you do it it catches the attention of
every person
more and more people participate in this
network
but how exactly to do it and the answer
is
ethereum mining by mining ethereum you
can participate in the ethereum network
as well as contribute to its performance
in crypto market
so in today's video we will focus on
ethereum mining and explore
its concepts hey everyone i am xiaomi
and i welcome you all to this new video
of simply known
on ethereum mining in this video
we will explore ethereum mining and
we'll go through some of the fascinating
concepts
and components revolving around it first
we will have an introduction to ethereum
then we will understand what is ethereum
mining
then we will explore why should we mine
ethereum
we will look into the types of ethereum
mining
and then we will understand how the
ethereum mining process
works then
we should explore how exactly to mine
ethereum
then we will discuss will the proof of
stake transaction kill proof of work
and then finally we will find out is
mining ethereum profitable
so without doing much ado let's get
started with the video
let's bring you up to speed on ethereum
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy decentralized applications
and make sure all the transactions are
cryptographically secured
in the network ether is the
cryptocurrency of ethereum
used to build decentralized applications
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments
ether basically acts as fuel for the
ethereum network
it tracks and facilitates all the
transactions
so that brings us to what is ethereum
mining
in simple words ethereum mining is a
process of creating
and adding a block of transaction to the
blockchain network of ethereum
it uses the proof of work consensus
mechanism for mining ethereum
all transactions taking place in the
ethereum network
needs to get approved by the miners
miners is a community of people using a
hashing script etas
to solve computationally hard puzzles
for successfully mining the blocks
of transactions in the ethereum
blockchain network
which helps secure the network from
attacks like hacking
or manipulation of identity
now let's understand why we need to mine
ethereum
the primary goal for mining ethereum is
to make money
a data mining contract of sectoring the
network into a relatively complex
but profitable business also miners
receive a certain amount as a reward for
mining
each block of the ethereum blockchain
network including the transaction fees
paid by the users thus italian mining
benefits each and everyone participating
in ethereum blockchain network
so what are the types of ethereum mining
ethereum mining can be performed in
three ways ethereum solar mining
ethereum coal mining and ethereum cloud
mining
in ethereum solar mining you will get
rewarded only if you solve the puzzle
and mine dietary block first
since here you are competing with many
people and companies
you have to be very good at your work
also solar mining is only profitable
when you have plenty of resources with
you
like 100 plus graphics cards
and in solo mining having so much
equipment may use a lot of electricity
and space leading to high electricity
bills and not everyone has a
considerable amount of area needed
intake and coal mining is the easiest
and fastest way to get started with
itaria mining
in this you work along with other people
together in a single pool
and if someone from the pool gets the
hash code correctly
they share the reward among everyone in
the pool
we should consider a few important
factors before joining a pool
like pool size minimum payout and pool
fee
pool size determines the number of
blocks you find in the ethereum network
and it shares rewards as the number of
miners increases the chances to get
rewards
also increase minimum payout is the
minimum amount of ethereum you need to
mine before
it gets credited to your wallet and 40
is the amount you need to pay to
continue using the pool
this amount is percentage based on the
amount of ethereum you're mining
ethereum cloud mining you pay someone
else with the equipment to my ethereum
for you you pay some amount of money as
peace to them
for investing their time and resources
and in return
they provide you with the reward they
gained by the mining ethereum
bus this technique of mining ethereum
has some pros and cons to
suppose you're not responsible for any
equipment damage
you don't have to acquire all the
necessary equipment
and look for ample space to store it you
can set that
observe market and enjoy the reward for
your investment in interior mining
cons if the italian price drop then
there is no way
you are getting your money back the
money you invested or the fees
paid to the miner is lost and you can't
ask the other person to change the
equipment
according to your concern ethereum cloud
mining is considered a safer way for
mining service providers
the guarantee a profit for the resource
they have purchased
now let's understand how the ethereum
mining process works
ethereum mining follows a specific set
of steps to function
step 1 a user requests a transaction
with the help of the private key
of his digital wallet account
then the request is shared worldwide
with the ethereum network
next the requested transaction is added
to a list of pending transactions
that needs to be added to the ethereum
blockchain network
step 4 the miner then verifies and
validates
the requested transaction and perform a
complex mathematical puzzle
on the transaction data
step 5 once the request transaction is
verified
and it stores a copy of it in edm
the process of proof of work begins for
the respective block
step 6 when the notes of the ethereum
network verify
at the checksum of the state of the
miner's block matches the checksum
of the updated state of the email after
execution of
all transactions
step 7 only after that the block is
added to the ethereum blockchain network
step 8 on successfully mining the block
it rewards the miner
with some amount of ether in their
wallet the block reward of ethereum
is 3 ether
step nine the requested transaction is
approved
and credited for the respective wallet
or wallet
each transaction is mined only once but
every participant of the ethereum
network
verifies it this makes me curious
about how to mine ethereum
tools you will need to be an efficient
miner for ethereum
on your personal computer are an
ethereum wallet to store
all your currency on gpu drivers or
graphics card
with a minimum of 3gb ram a mining
software
suitable according to your hardware like
gpu
and a compatible operating system
windows 7 or 10
with 64 bit
before getting started with mining
iteration you need to create an ethereum
wallet to store
all your ether fresh model t and ledger
nano are the most
reliable and secure wallets in the
market of cryptocurrency
installing gpu drivers or graphics card
after creating your digital wallet you
need to update
all the hardware that is drives in your
system
you can use two types of graphics cards
they are amd graphics card
and nvidia graphics card
claymore is considered the best
processor for mining ethereum
on gp drivers now
we need to follow a few set of steps to
get started with mining
step one download the latest version of
claymore
dual miner for the operating system the
latest version
is claymore 11.0
step 2 click on the latest version of
windows and download the zip file
step 3 extract the files with claymore
11.0 to a folder on desktop for easy
access
open the folder to have a look at the
files
step 5. right click on start and then on
the edit
option
step 6. edit the start.txt file
and add these lines
step 7 choose your desired pool from
these recommendations
you can also find better search results
than these according to your region
step 8 type in your full address instead
of mining pool address
step nine save your start.txt file
within new updates remember while saving
select type as
all files
and step 10 once you save click on the
clay.bat file to begin mining ethereum
now let's explore will the proof of
state transition field trooper work
the newly introduced concept of ethereum
2.0
roadmaps plans to upgrade to proof of
stake
consensus algorithm in which it will
provide all
existing miners of the dairy network
with a limited time to earn
a return for the investment
this expected to be launched by the end
of 2021
or the starting of 2022. it was supposed
to be launched by october 2020
but the history of delays regarding this
update is worth talking about
nobody truly knows when ethereum 2.0
will be completed
and introduced to the crypto mining
world
now when we know all about ethereum
mining
this makes me wonder if ethereum mining
is profitable
the profit of any crypto mining majorly
depends on the cost of electricity
in that particular area as a rule
anything below
0.12 dollar per kilowatt consumes in an
hour
is considered profitable you can mine
ether
and turn it into a vital source of
income
by analyzing these figures like hash
rate of ethereum
block reward number of blocks per day
and the coin price
of ethereum
you can also use an iterating calculator
to figure out the daily revenue basing
it on these factors
or you can use this formula too
the predictions are made that the
ethereum price can rise and become more
stable in the coming few years
so it is an excellent opportunity to
invest in
and save an ethereum so
this is all about ethereum mining we
have almost reached the end of this
video
if i miss anything important do let me
know in the comment section
i hope you enjoyed this video on a daily
mind and learn something new from it if
you like this video
then please do hit the like button
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates and videos from
citywalk
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here